I have a full body red light and infrared light therapy device.
I have heard that mixing things about using this when you have cancer.
I currently have breast cancer, but I'm also using a rife machine.
What do you think about this? Thank you.
I don't think there's any problem with using red light therapy.
Infrared light therapy is just by two.
I will caution you that if you have an infrared light therapy that costs you less than five thousand dollars,
it's probably got less than one percent really true infrared light.
And I don't mean to burst anybody's bubble, but it's just that's just the truth.
True infrared therapy light, you know, it's going to be five six thousand dollars.
An infrared therapy, the positive of that is that you get this deep heat.
And that's where you end up with.
It's basically a hyperthermia, wherever you put that infrared.
And one of the ways that you'll know that it's a better infrared device, not just the cost,
is that there will be no light.
So in true infrared does not produce light.
I would not say in a red light therapy that claims to have infrared light.
It's not, it doesn't have benefits.
Light therapy has benefits.
But it's not going to go deep, and it's not going to produce deep heat.
So there's a lot of companies that use false data, or maybe I should say,
that steal research from that's out there that's not based upon their device.
You see that in like the PMF industry.
The research on PMF devices is, is all on high Gauss PMF devices.
And then companies that sell a PMF device that's a very low Gauss uses that same research
to say that this is what PMF does, PMF does.
And the truth is, and that's not what your PMF will do because you have a machine that produces 700 Gauss.
The research was done on a machine that produces 30,000 Gauss.
So you're just going to be careful with claims that are made by different companies.
But there certainly can be no harm done.
You just got to be careful with what machines you spent money on.